you might be wrong let me ask you how
many times was this wording screen
displayed Ted Cruz got up there and he
went after Zuckerberg for exactly how
Facebook has sort of intentionally
allowed children to see sexual material
Instagram also displayed the following
warning
screen to individuals who were searching
for child abuse
material the these results may contain
images of child sexual abuse and then
you gave users two
choices get
resources or see results
anyway Mr Zuckerberg what the hell were
you
[Music]
thinking all right Senator um the the
the basic science behind that is that
when people are searching for something
that is problematic it's often helpful
to rather than just blocking it to help
direct them towards something that um
that could be helpful for getting them
to get help in what I understand get
resources in what San universe is there
a link for C results anyway well because
we might be wrong we we try to trigger
this this uh warning or we tried to um
when we think that there's any chance
that the result okay you might be wrong
let me ask you how many times was this
wording screen displayed I don't know
but the but the know why don't you know
I I I don't know the answer to
that there it's like Zuckerberg they got
you they got you we we all get to take
you to resources right so you're for
whatever reason you've searched this
stuff you're struggling I don't know
whatever it is take resources get off
this addiction blah blah blah see
results anyway and Zuckerberg's trying
to say and as someone that's created a
tech company like I am sympathetic to
all of the issues that arise that you
don't even realize are issues and
everything else but how did they not
realize see results anyway someone
searching for child exploitation stuff
it's like no that should not be on the
platform like they have to have a
department and they do have a department
I believe that it's their job and what a
horrific job and now it can be enhanced
by AI of course so you don't need humans
doing it that have to go out there and
and see this stuff and and make that
judgment call and everything else so so
they really kind of nailed him on that
and Cruz went a little further one more
clip for you a potential pedophile
clicking on I'd like to see child porn
what did you do next when that happened
Senator I I think that an important
piece of context here is that any
context that we think is child sexual
Zucker that's called a question what did
you do next when someone clicked you may
be getting child sexual abuse images and
they click see results anyway what was
your next step you said you might be
wrong did anyone examine was it in fact
act child sexual abuse material did
anyone report that user did anyone go
and try to protect that child what did
you do next Senator we take down
anything that we think is sexual abuse
material on the service and we do did
anyone verify whether it was in fact
child sexual abuse
material Senator I don't know if if
every single Searchers we following up
on but did you report the people who
wanted it C do you want me to answer
your question I want you to answer the
question I'm asking did you report the
people who click see results anyway um
that's probably one of the factors that
we use in reporting and in general we've
reported more people and done more
reports like this to Nicki the national
Center of missing exploited children
than any other company in the industry
we proactively go out of our way across
our services to do this and have made I
think it's more than 26 million reports
which is more than the whole rest of the
industry combined so Mr Zuckerberg Mr
Zuckerberg your company and every social
media company needs to do much more
protect children anyway I'm showing you
all of this because it's an interesting
well first of it's catching fire online
and it's an interesting piece of the of
the puzzle that's sort of wrong with
everything right now right like the
material shouldn't be there there's no
system that's perfect you've got you
know congressmen who want perfect
answers to imperfect systems you've got
billionaires being hauled out and having
struggle sessions and everything else I
would say this this issue and this is
the real reason I want to talk about it
it it's basically the issue of our time
how will we behave with technology as AI
becomes more and more ubiquitous and you
will not be able to tell the difference
between an image that is a real image or
video let's say of the president saying
actually we we nuked in Mexico yesterday
and it's completely fake and you will
not be able to tell you know right now
there are little little tricks with AI
because it's not perfect yet where you
can kind of tell the mouths don't match
perfectly sometimes there are six
fingers instead of five some weird
things like that but all of this stuff
it it's coming it's on the way and until
we figure out how we're going to relate
to all of it and we know the fact that
now we have a generation at least
probably two generations of young people
who do have more anxiety whose suicide
rates are up and it's not purely because
of Facebook and Instagram and it's also
because of covid lockdowns and a bunch
more that by the way many senators and
Congress people were for uh but we've
got this toxic stew and we've got to
figure out how to extricate ourselves
from that otherwise
border Middle East Ukraine Russia
everything else those are those are
going to be secondary problems to a
society that's just going to be kind of
wandering around uh with a with a really
kind of scrambled eggs for brains and
that I would say is
problematic